[Musik]
Netze raus Boot klar
Helmut Zahn ist seit 40 Jahren
binnenfischer auf der oder
die Erinnerung an die öko-katastrophe
vom Sommer schmerzt noch immer
wenn man hier so wie diesen großen Wels
hier schwimmen sieht
blutet einem das Herz das ist doch ganz
normal da neben Lachen frisch
veränderter Karpfen so um die drei Kilo
rum also da sind mir doch bald die
Tränen gekommen
wer die oder Katastrophe zu verantworten
hat bis heute unklar fest steht nur wie
die Tiere gestorben sind der Sommer heiß
und trocken der Fluss warm und mit
Nährstoffen belastet
besonders entscheidend aber eine hohe
Salzkonzentration im Wasser der perfekte
Nährboden für eine ganz spezielle Alge
es ist die brackwasseralge branesium
parvum meine killeralge deren giftfische
tötet ihre massive Ausbreitung in der
oder belegen Satellitendaten die der
vorschall Tobias Goldhammer ausgewertet
hat
und man sieht dass sich im Juli schon um
Gleiwitz herum der Gleiwitzer Kanal eine
eigenblüte gebildet hat die sich dann
weiter oder abwärts ausbreitet weiteren
Flussverlauf sieht man dann eine große
eigenblüte im August um Breslau rum die
sich dann tatsächlich weiter auch oder
abwärts fortbewegt und im Jahr Mitte
August haben wir dann im Prinzip den
ganzen Flussverlauf eine große
eigenblüte die Salzkonzentration steigt
Anfang August so stark an dass die
messernde in Frankfurt oder die Werte
nicht mehr erfassen kann
woher aber kommt das viele Salz in der
oder
Spurensuche im Süden Polens dort wo die
Satellitendaten Mitte Juli erste große
Algenblüten zeigen in der Region um
catchers
größter Düngemittelhersteller das
Chemieunternehmen Gruppe a sorti hat
hier ein Werk
im Quellgebiet der unteren Oder ist die
oder ein weitgehend sauberer natürlicher
Fluss aber wenn wir uns diesen Gebiet
hier nähern befinden wir uns am
Gleiwitzer Kanal die Zahl der
Industrieanlagen ist hier massiv dies
ist eine enorme Belastung für die oder
ist Biologe und Vorstand der
schlesischen Universität in Kattowitz
wir fahren mit ihm die oder flussabwärts
der Grund nicht nur die Gruppe asotti
hat die Erlaubnis salzhaltiger Abwässer
in die oder einzuleiten das belegt diese
Liste einer polnischen Wasserbehörde die
frontal vorliegt demnach haben insgesamt
22 Unternehmen dafür eine Genehmigung
darunter Tagebau mit angrenzenden
Zementwerken braunkohleunternehmen und
Kupferminen den ganzen Fluss entlang
vollkommen legal
nach Recherchen von Frontal liegen an 34
Stellen entlang der Oder und ein Kanälen
die in den Fluss münden Genehmigungen
vor Abwässer einzuleiten
Resultate an diesem Hitzesommer extrem
hohe salzwerte eine sich ausbreitende
killeralge und 12 bis 50 Millionen tote
Fische
[Musik]
körther scuballa sieht daher nicht einen
Schuldigen an der Katastrophe sondern
ein systemisches versagen und das nicht
nur an der Oder
[Musik]
leider erfüllt mein Land nicht die
Anforderungen an die Abwasserentsorgung
und es wurde vor einer solchen Tragödie
gewarnt schätzungsweise 90 Prozent der
polnischen Flüsse sind in einem
schlechten Zustand
die oder Katastrophe sorgt für
diplomatische Verstimmungen zwischen
Polen und Deutschland
die deutsche Umweltministerin Steffi
Lemke fordert Konsequenzen
erwarte natürlich von der polnischen
Seite eine vollständige Aufklärung und
vollständige Transparenz darüber was
passiert ist Polen soll sich
rechtfertigen und Deutschland der Blick
auf idyllische Flusslandschaften drückt
wir sind in Deutschland was die Gewässer
betrifft einfach schlecht und kommen
nicht an die gesetzlichen Werte heran
Beispiel divera in Hessen und das
dortige Kalibergwerk
hier werden eingeleitet bis zu 1800
Gramm Milligramm Chlorid mehrere hundert
Milligramm Magnesium dann kommt noch
Kalium dazu und die drei salzkomponenten
zusammenhauen hier die Ökologie
auseinander auch hier an der Werra sind
die Einleitungen vollkommen legal nach
frontalrecherchen erlaubt die aktuelle
Genehmigung sogar noch höhere salzwerte
als in der oder wie kann das sein das
hessische Umweltministerium meint man
könne oder und Vera nicht vergleichen
und teilt mit Zitat
an der Werra erfolgt die Einleitung
seitseitiger Abwässer seit Jahrzehnten
für Naturschützer eine irrwitzige
Erklärung schließlich leben in der Werra
nur noch wenige Fischarten und die
leiden unter Krankheiten
das sind typische Krankheitsbilder der
Fische in der Werra Fische sind krank
durch das Salz in der Folge gehen dann
die Schuppen weg es kommen die offenen
fleischpartien zu Tage und die Fische
leiden natürlich darunter es sind auch
nicht einzeln sondern Massen an Fischen
die so geschädigt sind und wenn Fische
schreien würden dort vor Schmerzen dann
wäre es hier laut dann könnten wir hier
nicht in Ruhe stehen
dabei sollten Deutschlands Flüsse doch
sauber werden weniger Salz geringe
Nährstoffbelastung gesündere Fische ein
guter ökologischer Zustand der
Oberflächengewässer so verlangt es eine
EU-Richtlinie bis spätestens 2015 sollte
dieses Ziel komplett erreicht sein heute
sieben Jahre später ist die Werra immer
noch in einem miserablen Zustand
das hessische Umweltministerium hat
dafür eine erstaunliche Erklärung
demnach könnten an
Wasserkörper bei denen die Erreichung
der bewirtschaftungsziele nicht möglich
oder unverhältnismäßig aufwändig ist
weniger strenge bewirtschaftungsziele
festgelegt werden
im Klartext der Werra geht es so
schlecht dass Ausnahmeregelungen die
Ziele aufweichen ein bürokratentrick
der Zustand der deutschen Flüsse
katastrophal
nur 7,6 Prozent der Gewässer die wie die
Vera in die Weser münden sind in gutem
ökologischen Zustand
beim Rhein sind es 11,9 Prozent bei der
Elbe 5,5 und an der oder nur 2,7 und bei
der Ems erreicht nicht ein einziges
Gewässer den guten Zustand
also Deutschland hält praktisch
flächendeckend die Wasser die Zielwerte
der wasserrahmenrichtlinien nicht ein ob
das in Norddeutschland ist im
Grundwasser mit den zu hohen Stickstoff
aus der Landwirtschaft ob das hier an
der Werra ist mit den
haushaltskonzentrationen
Deutschland versagt beim Gewässerschutz
der Vorsitzende der
Umweltministerkonferenz mit einem
Eingeständnis der ambitionierte Weg den
wir uns vorgenommen haben und das was
wir erreicht haben passt tatsächlich
nicht zusammen nun ein neues Versprechen
für das Jahr 2027 das Ziel 27 ist 18
Prozent zu erreichen das ist angesichts
der Herausforderung groß aber natürlich
mit Blick darauf dass wir eigentlich
100% erreichen müssen tatsächlich noch
weit von dem eigentlichen Ziel entfernt
alles soll also besser werden doch die
Realität sieht anders aus in den
vergangenen Jahren ist es noch
schlechter geworden bei
zweiflussgebieten Nachfrage bei der
Bundesumweltministerin kein Interview
mit Steffi Lemke
die Antwort ihres Ministeriums schwammig
auch die Klimakrise habe Auswirkungen
auf den Zustand der Flüsse die
Bundesregierung gibt sich machtlos
Thomas norgall vom Bund sieht in diesem
Versagen Grund zur Klage wir haben 2018
eine sehr umfangreiche Beschwerde
eingegeben an die EU danach ist nichts
passiert und jetzt müsste eigentlich die
EU sozusagen Deutschland verklagen eine
Katastrophe wie in der oder ist auch in
anderen deutschen Flüssen möglich Helmut
Zahn muss mit den Folgen leben
[Musik]
wir haben für uns beschlossen
also gerade die oder Bestände
weitestgehend in Ruhe zu lassen und
damit genügend leichtfische übrig
bleiben
er und seine Kollegen hoffen darauf dass
sich die oder erholen kann nach der
großen öko-katastrophe mit Millionen
veränderter Fische